bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de freud et de la religion dans la
précédente vidéo consacrée à des cartes
on a vu à quel point les domaines de la
foi et de la raison pouvait être des
domaines totalement irréconciliables on
a vu qu'en voulant démontrer l'existence
de dieu par des preuves rationnelle des
cartes avaient plutôt contribuer à
montrer les limites de la raison et à
quel point foi et raison semble vouée à
rester des étrangers l'un pour l'autre
et on va voir aujourd'hui avec freud
qu'une autre approche du rapport entre
foi et raison est possible il ne s'agira
pas de démontrer rationnellement
l'existence de dieu mais il s'agira de
comprendre rationnellement les origines
de la croyance en dieu il s'agira de
comprendre pourquoi l'homme croire
pourquoi l'homme croit en dieu et
pourquoi il a créé la religion freud est
à un médecin du 19e et du 20e siècle
fondateur de la psychanalyse et c'est
quelqu'un qui s'inscrit résolument dans
le courant matérialiste c'est à dire que
pour lui la religion les croyances
religieuses sont d'abord des
constructions de l'esprit humain
pour lui ce n'est pas dieu qui a créé
l'homme c'est l'homme qui a créé dieu
donc pour freud on ne peut pas rendre
compte rationnellement de l'existence de
dieu
si vous préférez on peut pas prouver son
existence mais par contre on peut rendre
compte rationnellement de la croyance en
dieu c'est à dire qu'on peut comprendre
les raisons pour lesquelles l'homme a
créé dieu et aujourd'hui on va voir
quelle explication donne freud à la
création par les hommes de dieu alors
freud avait lui-même un rapport assez
ambigu à la religion il est né et a
grandi dans une famille de tradition
juive jeudi de tradition parce que sa
famille n'était déjà plus tellement
pratiquante mais malgré tout freud a été
baigné dans la culture juive et plus
précisément dans la culture talmudique
et donc il connaît bien la religion
qu'il connaît bien le monothéisme
il a lu les textes il a lu la bible
lorsqu'il était enfant il a même
consacré l'un de ses livres à moïse et
au monothéisme
donc on ne peut pas dire que c'était
quelqu'un qui rejetait la religion
tradition familiale il rejetait la
religion parce qu'en tant que
rationaliste matérialiste il plaçait sa
foi dans la science plutôt que dans la
religion
mais même si freud n'était pas lui même
croyant même s'il était hostile à la
religion il s'y intéresse parce qu'ils y
voient un phénomène humain tout à fait
révélateur de la nature humaine tout à
fait révélateur de la nature de son
psychisme et de son besoin d'idoles
freud était absolument fasciné par le
psychisme humain et pour lui toute
croyance est d'abord la manifestation
d'un désir je vous renvoie ma vidéo sur
freud et l'inconscient freud considère
que notre vie psychique est entièrement
gouverné par nos désirs
ce désir cette pulsion sexuelle et
animale fraude considère qu'elle est à
l'origine de tous les phénomènes
psychiques
pour lui il n'ya pas de séparation il
n'y a pas de démarcation entre la vie
sexuelle et la vie psychique puisqu'en
réalité la vie psychique n'est que le
résultat n'est que le prolongement de la
vie sexuelle
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on pense tout le
temps au sexe mais ça veut simplement
dire que la pulsion sexuelle ne cesse
jamais d'alimenter notre psychisme
ça signifie que toutes nos pensées et
tous nos désirs sont d'origine sexuelle
alors vous allez me dire en quoi est ce
que la religion peut bien avoir une
origine sexuelle effectivement dit comme
ça ça paraît assez improbable apparaît
assez étrange
en fait c'est pas exactement comme ça
qu'il faut comprendre les choses pour
comprendre le phénomène religieux et la
croyance des hommes en dieu il va être
nécessaire nous dit freud de revenir aux
fondements
ce que nous dit freud donc c'est que
l'être humain est d'abord un être de
désir
un être de pulsions c'est un être qui
est fondamentalement animé par
l'agressivité par la violence par
l'instinct de destruction de destruction
et d'autodestruction autrement dit
fondamentalement l'être humain n'est pas
adapté à la vie sociale et quand je dis
qu'il n'est pas adapté à la vie sociale
il faut comprendre qu'il n'est pas
naturellement enclins à vivre avec les
autres
il n'est pas naturellement enclins à
respecter l'autre l'homme est animé par
sa pulsion pulsions
désirante pulsions de domination il
n'est pas naturellement altruiste et pas
naturellement bienveillant avec ses
semblables
et c'est parce que l'être humain est
animé de cette pulsion d'agressivité
qu'il a besoin d'être gouvernée par un
chef un chef c'est à dire une autorité
une autorité qui va canaliser la pulsion
de la foule afin d'éviter que le peuple
ne s'autodétruise donc là vous
reconnaissez l'anthropologie de obs
l'idée que l'homme est un loup pour
l'homme et chez freud de la foule ne
peut être canalisée dans sa pulsion que
s'ils pèsent sur elle la menace d'un
châtiment
autrement dit c'est par crainte du
châtiment que la foule va en rabattre
sur son agressivité
c'est donc là encore une passion qui
vient canaliser une autre passion c'est
à dire que c'est la crainte qui vient
canaliser l'agressivité c'est la crainte
du chef
la crainte de l'autorité qui va pousser
les individus à rester pacifique est à
retenir leurs pulsions à la réprimer et
à la refouler la répression et le
refoulement ce sont des phénomènes
psychiques par lesquels on empêche la
pulsion de s'extérioriser l'empêchent de
se manifester et de causer des dégâts
vous imaginez bien que si à chaque fois
que vous sortez dans la rue vous avez la
possibilité de vous faire sauter dessus
par quelqu'un qui va vouloir vous tuer
ou qu'il va vouloir vous agressez d'une
manière ou d'une autre
là ce serait un petit peu compliqué de
vivre en société donc il faut bien d'une
manière ou d'une autre que les individus
se retiennent et se retenir
c'est à dire contredire sa pulsion
l'empêcher de se manifester
saissac freud appelle la répression et
le refoulement la différence entre les
deux étant simplement que la répression
s'effectue à un niveau conscient tandis
que le refoulement lui s'effectue à un
niveau inconscient et donc ce besoin de
la foule d'être sous l'autorité d'un
chef
la chef qui détient le pouvoir et qui
peut inspirer la crainte à la foule
freud y voit une analogie avec le
comportement infantile la tendance
infantile à avoir besoin d'une autorité
parce que pour freud de la foule est
infantile elles et infantile par essence
et parce qu'elle est infantile elle a
besoin d'un père elle a beau
loin d'une autorité directrice
directrice au sens où elle va lui donner
une direction
et pourquoi est ce que la foule a besoin
d'être guidé et bien parce que
l'autorité ça rassure l'autorité ça
donne un cadre
ça donne des repères l'autorité c'est ce
qui permet de ne pas se poser de
questions et donc paradoxalement c'est
ce qui permet de se déresponsabiliser de
s'abandonner au contrôle de l'autorité
l'enfant est sous l'autorité de ses
parents c'est ce qui fait que ce sont
ses parents qui sont responsables de ces
actes là évidemment l'absence de
responsabilité de l'enfant
ça ne veut pas dire que l'enfant a le
droit de faire tout et n'importe quoi
justement c'est parce que l'enfant va
devenir un adulte qui doit acquérir le
sens de la responsabilité
mais tant qu'il est enfant tant qu'il
est sous l'autorité parentale
c'est le parent qui endosse la
responsabilité et donc l'autorité
parentale
l'enfant peut parfois la rejeter la
remettre en cause mais n'empêche que
cette autorité elle le rassure elle le
rassure parce qu'elle lui permet de ne
pas avoir à assumer les conséquences de
ses décisions et à leur assure également
parce que l'autorité parentale va de
pair avec la protection qu'est ce que
c'est que la figure paternelle la figure
paternelle
c'est la figure qui inspire à la fois
l'amour et la crainte la figure
paternelle
c'est celle à qui on craindre à mener
une mauvaise note
c'est celle dont on redoute la réaction
si elle apprend qu'on a fait quelque
chose de mal
c'est la figure qui porte en elle à la
fois la promesse d'une protection et la
menace d'un châtiment et c'est pour
cette raison que dans un schéma éducatif
traditionnel la figure du père est
considéré comme structurantes
structurante au sens où elle donne des
repères des repères entre le bien et le
mal des repères entre l'acte juste et la
faute
l'acte juste qui recevra une récompense
est la faute qui sera puni
évidemment c'est un paradoxe parce qu'on
retrouve dans cette figure du père deux
aspects contradictoires à la fois la
protection et la punition
le père est à la fois aimer et redouté
mais pour freud il n'y a pas de
contradiction à éprouver des sentiments
contradictoires c'est à dire qui
éprouvait des sentiments contradictoires
pour freud c'est un petit peu le lot
commun
la fascination peut aller de pair avec
la répulsion
de la même façon qu'on peut être attiré
par des choses qui nous font du mal
c'est pas incompatibles ce n'est pas
illogique et selon freud c'est parce que
l'être humain a besoin d'une figure
autoritaire suprême qui l'a inventé dieu
et donc ce n'est pas un hasard si dans
la plupart des religions monothéistes
dieu est représenté sous les traits
d'une figure paternelle
on dit bien dieu le père parce que le
père c'est celui qui assure l'ordre qui
récompensent équipe unie qui donne une
direction et dont la force lui permet
d'imposer ces décrets un père qui peut
déployer une colère terrifiante mais qui
peut aussi se montrer protecteur et
c'est pourquoi le dieu de l'ancien
testament est un dieu absolument
impitoyable envers les fautes humaines
on pense évidemment à l'exemple de
sodome et gomorrhe dans la bible et dans
le coran avec la destruction de la ville
de sodome par le souffre et le feu ce
dom dont le péché est énorme nous dit la
genèse vous savez c'est quand dieu
envoie deux de ses anges pour vérifier
que le péché est caractérisée et lorsque
la confirmation lui ai donné dieu décide
de détruire sodome et la ville voisine
comores afin de laver le péché ouais
c'est une manière un petit peu
autoritaire d' exercer la justice mais
ça montre là encore que la punition est
associé à cette idée de justice à cette
idée de rétablir le bien est donc en
créant dieu les hommes ont créé une
sorte de père surpuissant père
omnipotent et omniscient omniscient
signifiant qu' on ne peut rien lui
cacher c'est ça aussi qui inspire la
crainte de dieu chez les hommes c'est
son omniscience on ne peut pas pêcher en
cachette on peut pas pêcher quand dieu a
le dos tourné
parce que dieu il a des yeux derrière la
tête on peut pas l'arnaqué
c'est ça l'idée on peut par
ah qu'est dieu et faire passer le péché
sous le tapis c'est pas possible
et comme il est omnipotent comme il a
les pleins pouvoirs car ça signifie
qu'on ne pourra pas s'extraire de son
châtiment on pourra pas empêcher que la
sanction tombait autrement dit qu aucun
péché ne restera impuni
d'où l'invention de l'enfer qui est le
lieu où finiront les méchants at-il et
promis une vie éternelle de souffrance
tandis que les justes ceux qui auront
accompli le bien eux auront la
récompense d'une vie heureuse
éternel donc c'est ce schéma binaire ce
schéma dualiste entre la récompense est
la punition qui caractérise le mieux
selon freud la figure paternelle la
figure paternelle elle est à la fois
bienveillante et protectrice mais elle
est également sévère et punitive et le
lien entre ces deux tendances ces deux
pôles c'est la justice la justice qui
récompense les bons et qui punit les
méchants vous voyez quand je dis ça
remet ça à l'air très infantile
ça a l'air très puéril mais justement
pour freud c'est parce que c'est
infantile que c'est la réalité c'est
parce que c'est infantile que ça
correspond très exactement à ce que sont
les hommes les hommes sont des enfants
et en tant qu'enfant ils ont besoin de
schéma binaire
ils ont besoin d'une autorité
législatrice qui leur indiquent
clairement la direction élan pause
demandé mais qu'est ce qui fait que
l'être humain l'être humain adulte se
comporte comme un enfant parce que
l'enfant qu'ils aient besoin de
protection on peut le comprendre
on peut le comprendre parce que par
nature l'enfant est faible est faible il
est vulnérable face au monde
quand un enfant ce fait embêter à
l'école par un plus grand si ses parents
lui ont pas appris à viser le menton
l'enfant va appeler ses parents à la
rescousse ses parents où son grand frère
son cousin en tout cas à une personne
plus grande que lui plus forte que lui
qui soit à même de le défendre
donc c'est la fragilité c'est la
vulnérabilité qui pousse au besoin d'une
protection
il y a des six tués
sion ou l'adulte est semblable à
l'enfant l'adulte aussi a besoin de
protection l'adulte aussi a besoin
d'être rassuré non pas parce qu'il ne
sait pas se défendre mais parce qu'il
est soumis à de grandes préoccupations
et ses préoccupations ce sont tout
simplement les préoccupations
métaphysiques
alors quelles sont ses préoccupations
métaphysiques qui font que l'homme a
besoin d'une instance supérieure
et bien c'est par exemple la question de
la vie après la mort c'est également la
question de l'origine du monde
toutes ces questions métaphysiques qui
hante l'esprit des hommes depuis l'aube
de l'humanité et qui n'ont pas trouvé de
réponse nous naissons nous grandissons
et nous serons dans l'ignorance de ses
réponses
et le pire c'est qu'on en a conscience
c'est qu'on a conscience d'être dans
cette ignorance métaphysique et c'est ça
la malédiction humaine finalement c'est
que ayant conscience de la mort mais
dans en même temps dans l'incapacité de
trouver une résolution à cette angoisse
est bien l'homme va inventer lui-même la
réponse va créer la réponse est la
réponse c'est dieu l'homme a créé la
réponse parce que il est obligé de créer
une réponse
ces cinq dit freud l'origine du besoin
de dieu est donc l'origine de la
création de dieu dieu va être ce par
quoi la réponse à la question de la mort
va être apportée évidemment quand on n'a
pas de réponse on crée la réponse qui
nous arrange on crée la réponse qui va
apaiser notre angoisse c'est un peu le
pendant de la solution de pascal parce
qu'elle nous disait que parce qu'il est
incapable de demeurer en repos dans une
chambre
autrement dit parce qu'il est incapable
de faire face à l'idée de la mort
l'homme a besoin de dévier son attention
par le divertissement il a besoin de
s'occuper l'esprit pour ne pas être
absorbé dans la spirale du
questionnement métaphysique et bien pour
freud la spirale du questionnement
métaphysique va trouver une solution
dans la création de dieu comme réponse à
l'angoissé de la mort donc on tient
finalement là les deux réponses humaines
à l' angoisse métaphysique de la mort
dieu et le divertissement de là
son l'être humain se posent la question
de l'origine du monde et on est bien
d'accord que si tout ça n'est que le
fruit du hasard bien se pose
immédiatement la question du sens de
notre existence
et si on pose la question du sens de
l'existence
on pose en même temps la question de sa
valeur si la vie humaine n'a pas de sens
si elle n'est pas l'oeuvre d'une volonté
bien ce moment là elle perd toute valeur
elle n'est qu'un accident du hasard et à
ce moment là
à quoi bon vivre à quoi bon être là en
attribuant la création l'univers adieu
les croyants peuvent ainsi évacué
l'ignorance de l'origine et ce faisant
leur existence acquiert un sens donc
vous voyez que aussi bien pour la
question de la mort que pour la question
de l'origine
l'absence de réponse produits en l'homme
une angoisse et c'est cette angoisse
absolument terrifiante absolument
insupportable qui va pousser les hommes
à créer leurs propres réponses où il va
pousser les hommes a inventé un être
tout puissant créateur de l'univers afin
d'apaiser leurs angoisses l'angoissent
infantile de l'inconnu je précise ici
que cette vision la religion développé
par freud on la trouve essentiellement
développée dans un de ses livres qui
s'appelle l'avenir d'une illusion publié
en 1927
et si je ne le précise que maintenant
c'est justement pour qu'on s'arrête un
instant sur ce terme d'illusions je vous
ai dit en début de vidéo que freud était
quelqu'un de très hostile envers la
religion et on pourrait voir dans
l'utilisation de ce terme d'illusions un
jugement péjoratif sur la religion et
donc par conséquent un jugement
péjoratif sur le besoin humain de se
rattacher à dieu mais en réalité il faut
entendre le mot illusion dans son sens
primaire dans son sens étymologique
illusion ça vient du verbe latin
ils louent des raies qui signifie jouer
jouer au sens théâtral au sens de
représentation et il se trouve justement
que une illusion c'est une
représentation une représentation
mentale une représentation de l'esprit
une illusion c'est une projection c'est
une image c'est un fantasme fantasia en
grec
ça veut dire images freud n'est pas du
tout mais
dix ans envers cette illusion simplement
il veut dire que c'est un besoin humain
de se raccrocher à des images se
raccrocher à des représentations
parce que sinon la vie serait trop
insupportable
l'esprit humain a besoin de créer des
fictions pour pouvoir se maintenir dans
l'existence et nous autres êtres humains
nous ne pourrions pas supporter
l'existence
si nous n'avions pas de réponse à ces
questions métaphysiques ou pourrions pas
maintenir notre équilibre psychique
si nous vivions en permanence avec
l'idée que notre existence n'a aucun
sens que notre vie n'a pas de valeur et
que nous ne vivons que pour mourir
ce serait pas supportable comment vivre
avec ça vous connaissez l'expression du
a créé l'homme à son image et on peut
dire que chez freud c'est l'homme qui a
créé dieu à son image il a créé dieu de
telle sorte à lui faire dire les
réponses dont nous avons besoin dont
nous avons besoin pour donner un sens à
notre vie mais dieu n'est pas simplement
le créateur du monde
dieu n'est pas simplement celui que nous
rejoindront après notre mort il est
aussi celui qui va réparer les
injustices commises ici bas dieu qui
récompense les justes et qui punit les
mauvais ça aussi c'est un besoin humain
fondamental
le besoin de justice le besoin que si
nous faisons le bien sur terre nous
recevions un meilleur sort que ceux qui
font le mal l'idée que parce que nous
nous efforçons de rester dans la voie du
juste
nous serons récompensés de cet effort ça
aussi pour freud c'est une illusion mais
c'est une
jean nécessaire c'est une illusion
protectrice de l'humanité car si nous
nous comportions comme nos instincts
nous pousse à nous comporter si nous
faisions qu'obéir à notre pulsion
l'humanité s'autodétruiraient toute vie
serait impossible
c'est en ce sens
dieu apparaît comme un besoin un besoin
de répondre à l'angoissé humaines de la
mort un besoin de répondre à la question
du sens de l'existence a besoin de
savoir que tôt ou tard justice sera
faite avoir foi en dieu c'est porter
l'espoir d'une réponse à ces questions
c'est avoir l'espérance que nous ne
sommes pas là pour rien que nous avons
raison d'exister donc je maintenant vous
lira un extrait du texte de freud
l'avenir d'une illusion dans lequel on
trouve un assez bon résumé de la
conception freudienne de la religion
je cite les idées religieuses qui
professent d'être des dogmes ne sont pas
le résidu de l'expérience ou le résultat
final de la réflexion elles sont des
illusions la réalisation des désirs les
plus anciens les plus forts les plus
pressants de l'humanité le secret de
leur force et la force de ses désirs
nous savons déjà l'impression
terrifiante de la détresse infantile
avait éveillé le besoin d'être protégés
protéger en étant et mes besoins
auxquels le père a satisfait la
reconnaissance du fait que cette
détresse dure toute la vie a fait que
l'homme s'est cramponné à un père un
père cette fois plus puissant
l'angoissent humaine en face des dangers
de la vie ça pèse à la pensée du reg
bienveillant de la providence divine
l'institution d'un ordre moral de
l'univers assure la réalisation des
exigences de la justice si souvent
demeurait y réaliser dans les
civilisations humaines et la
prolongation de l'existence terrestre
par une vie future fournit les cadres du
temps et le lieu où ses désirs se
réaliseront des réponses aux questions
que se pose la curiosité humaine
touchant ses énigmes la genèse de
l'univers le rapport entre le corporel
et le spirituel s'élabore suivant les
prémices du système religieux et c'est
un formidable allègements pour l'âme
individuel que de voir les conflits de
l'enfance émaner du complexe paternel
conflit jamais entièrement résolu lui
être pour ainsi dire enlever et recevoir
une solution acceptée de tous
derrière la question de la religion ce
qui se pose c'est la question de la foi
et l'être humain est un être deux fois
la fois fidèle en latin c'est ce qui a
donné fidel fidel c'est celui qui suit
une voie la fois nous
suivre une voie parce que la foi nous
fait croire dans la valeur de ce que
nous faisons l'homme est un être deux
fois parce que l'homme est un être de
sens
il pourra placer sa foi dans dieu comme
il pourra placer sa foi dans l'homme on
peut aussi placer sa foi dans les
principes dans des valeurs des idéaux
mais alors on sort peut-être de la
promesse d'une récompense on sort
peut-être de la promesse du paradis
parce qu'un principe une valeur un idéal
ne nous accueillera pas forcément auprès
de lui après notre mort ce qui nous
accueillera ce sera la satisfaction
d'avoir suivi la voie du juste
ce sera la conviction d'avoir oeuvré
pour le bien et d'avoir par son
comportement par ses actes ou ses
paroles donner du sens la foi c'est ce
qui anime tout être humain
désireux d'oeuvrer pour le bien est
conscient qu'il y a au delà de nous des
choses qui nous dépassent les principes
des valeurs des idéaux qui mérite que
nous acceptions la mort qui mérite que
nous acceptions de ne pas savoir je vous
remercie
[Musique]